bonjour philippe desan merci d'être avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france alors
la hongrie et la pologne bloc qu'un par
leur veto le versement du budget
européen qui allaient refuse que
l'attribution des fonds bruxelles soient
liés au respect de l'état de droit
pourquoi selon vous au parce que le
respect de l'état de droit suppose que
la cour de justice européenne statut et
impose à tous les pays le respect de
certaines règles non seulement sur la
façon dont fonctionnent les justices à
l'échelon national mais également ça
conditionne par exemple la liberté de la
presse
la souveraineté des pays sur leur
volonté ou réticente à accueillir des
quotas de migrants qui serait fixée par
bruxelles
ça va également interférer avec des
décisions heureux d'y apporter
domestique et la hongrie et la pologne
ne sont pas les premières à s'être vu
opposer le droit européen puisque même
l'allemagne dans le cadre de sa critique
des programmes de d'injection de la bce
l'allemagne et c'est signifier que c'est
la cour de justice européenne
ce sont ces arrêts qui l'emportent sur
par exemple des avis négatifs de la cour
constitutionnelle allemande justement
sur le fait de procéder à de la création
monétaire ou à la mutualisation des
dettes
donc on voit que la cour de justice
européenne est aujourd'hui à un organe
tout puissant et dont on découvre
finalement la toute puissance sans qu'on
met vraiment vu la chose venir et la
cour de justice européenne statue
également sur les contributions des
diverses ce pays au budget européen
donc on va dire que là
beaucoup de pays refusent de se voir
imposer des décisions par un organisme
sur lequel finalement personne n'a la
main et personne ne peut s'opposer
alors on rappelle la pologne et la
hongrie font aussi partie des pays
bénéficiaires de ces fonds européens
angers lens versement ces pays se met
aussi en danger non oui on va dire que
d'un côté il se tire une balle dans le
pied
le sabbat il fait frissonner des pays
comme l'italie l'espagne le portugal et
la grèce qui ont vraiment besoin du
versement des sommes prévues dans le
plan européen on sauf qu'il faut quand
même mettre les choses en perspective
aux états unis au mois de mars dernier
ils ont mis en place à un plan de 2200
milliards qui a été délivré
immédiatement auquel se sont arrêtés 500
milliards de plus au mois de mai et puis
on discute actuellement de vie d'un plan
de 3000 milliards c'est-à-dire 15 % du
pib américain alors que en europe
on en est encore à débloquer un plan de
750 milliards dont 350 milliards
seulement correspondent à des prêts
mutualisés pour qu on comprend bien que
le blocage il est beaucoup plus
politique qu'économique
mais il faut également relativiser par
exemple la france attend 40 milliards
quand on voit combien se chiffre
aujourd'hui le coût de la crise du coc
vide on voit que c'est quand même pas
des montants absolument considérable
mais même si ça ça met du beurre dans
les épinards de la plaine de la slovénie
de larmes hongrie c'est quand même pas
des sommes qui conditionnent la survie
de deux de ces pays donc on va dire que
il ya il ya évidemment un jeu
de petit chantage parce que ne pas se
voir délivrer les sommes prévues
c'est quand même pas encore complètement
vital ça l'est davantage en fait pour
l'italie et l'espagne
philippe béchade qu'est ce que le
parlement européen pourrait faire à
court terme là pour tenter de faire
avancer justement ces négociations alors
là la france n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai dit que comme unanimité est
impossible à réunir à 27 avec chacun
ayant ses propres barrières penser que
l'on connaît il faut trouver un système
où peut-être c'est la majorité qualifiée
donc ça c'est déjà pour certaines
décisions passerait la majorité le
qualifié qui l'emportent
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire à 100 au
lac ça veut dire qu'à ce moment là la
cour de justice européenne se transforme
en un véritable gendarme et impose donc
les décisions monétaires par exemple là
en ce monde et 24 au 27 et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est susceptible
de faire éclater l'europe parce que à ce
moment là on est on est dans un système
qui n'est plus démocratique qui devient
un système autoritaire et là c'est un
repoussoir terrible donc de mettre en
place une décision excluant ceux qui ne
veulent pas me prendre par le risque
politique est très important alors merci
désolé on manque de temps ou bien à bien
sûr revenir vers vous a lors de nos
prochains jours de nos prochaines
éditions en tout cas merci beaucoup
philippe béchade d'avoir été avec nous
on rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en
chef de la bourse au quotidien merci
beaucoup